je me tourne vers vous il ya cette carte
derrière vous on a beaucoup parlé ces
derniers jours de la stratégie
d'encerclement de contournement des
heureuses pour atteindre des sas et
l'objectif final nicolas if one doline
en parlait il ya quelques instants le
gouverneur de la région déclaraient tout
à l'heure que les russes avaient été
finalement repoussée par les forces du
cren yen ce matin la ligne de front elle
extrêmement mouvant dans cette région
mais les objectifs russes restent
inchangées et ce depuis le début de la
guerre oui absolument ce alors ce
retrait partiel russe n'est pas vraiment
significatif à l'échelle de l'ukraine ça
n'est pas une bataille décisive ce qui
est important c'est ce noeud routier il
ya effectivement au nord d'odessa au
nord-est de nos méthodes et sa 1e
routier qui est absolument capital
puisque il mènera justement directement
faire la capitale et permettra on le
voit très clairement sur cette carte de
boucler toute la moitié est ce les deux
tiers est quasiment de l'ukraine ce qui
isolera
définitivement les contingents ukrainien
qui se trouve à l'intérieur du
territoire de quelque chose d'absolument
essentiel c'est les flux logistiques qui
arrivent de l'ouest puisque vous voyez
ccc marquage sur la carte qui marque les
frappes aériennes zito mire elle a
effectivement qui vise d'abord les
structures aéroportuaires par lesquelles
l'armée ukrainienne est ravitaillée en
armement en munitions en vivre depuis
les puissances étrangères qui
soutiennent l'ukraine et notamment les
pays frontaliers mais on voit d'autres
frappes aériennes qui marquent notamment
les axes routiers qui sont de véritables
pénétrante qui partent d'ouest en est et
qui ravitaille l'ensemble de l'armée
ukrainienne et ce ravitaillement est
absolument essentiel puisqu'il s'agit
des fameux missiles stinger qui font
tomber les avions russes les fameux
missiles javeline qui détruisent les
chars russes donc sans ce matériel sans
ces équipements évidemment que l'effort
que peut produire l'armée ukrainienne
ici est voué à s'éteindre absolument ici
si l'armée ukrainienne est coupé de ses
arrière logistique il n'ya plus
d'actions possibles c'est bel et bien
l'objectif de l'armée russe en prenant
au dessin d'abord contrôler cet axe
routier qui mènera vers la capitale et
puis il faut y ajouter une menace qui
est prise très au sérieux par les états
majors américains qui rappelons le ont
un regard extrêmement précis de ce qui
se passe en ukraine paradoxalement grâce
à leurs moyens satellitaires nos moyens
d'observation et les bases qu'ils ont
partout autour de l'ukraine et qui leur
donne une écoute des capacités des
coupes qui leur permet d'anticiper la
manoeuvre russe tout ce renseignement
permet d'affirmer au pentagone qu'une
avec une opération amphibie être en
préparation au large des côtes de la mer
noire et qu'elle finira par voir avoir
lieu et complètera l'effort qui arrive
de l'est de ce contingent russe qui est
sur le point ou en tout cas à
l'intention de s'emparer d'odessa